how are you guys doing it's been such a
long time hasn't it since we've spoken
casually and informally here in the car
speaking about important matters
and um today inshallah i wanna do a
clarificatory video basically on the
issue of using philosophy in dawa
now um this has been quite a sticky
subject especially with some segments i
have to say you know tiny segments puny
segments of the salafi community not all
the sellers of course not the celebrity
community no definitely not
some segments but even for them and for
their followers
i make this concession
i want to make sure that everyone is on
the same page first of all what is
philosophy
philosophy is
as i understand it okay
and according to cambridge dictionary
it's i'm paraphrasing here but it's the
use of reason it is actually the use of
reason to understand
um things about existence knowledge and
existence
now this is my understanding of
philosophy
in other words
rational arguments intellectual
arguments and philosophical arguments
for me
can almost be used
interchangeably let me say that one time
someone says i want to make rational
arguments for me they are making
philosophical arguments and if they're
making philosophical arguments they are
attempting to make rational arguments if
they're making intellectual arguments
they're making philosophical arguments
and so on and so forth
that's
that's what we mean by philosophy now
what we don't mean by philosophy is
greek logic
some people have come out unfortunately
have strawman my position have lied
actually quite openly maybe it wasn't a
lie i have to give them the benefit of
the doubt maybe it was just a slip of
the tongue maybe it was a mistake or
whatever and said that
my position basically is that you have
to use greek logic in order to come to
the truth of islam
i've never made such a statement in my
entire life i don't even think i've made
such a statement of my dreams
i don't think even i made such a
statement in my dreams
and so having said that greek philosophy
or hellenistic philosophy aristotelian
sorry greek logic
or holistic logic or aristotelian logic
is not
why intent by the word
philosophy i don't think it's what
anyone
intends with the word
philosophy
so if you're making an argument for
god's existence for
example and those the word the exact
wording is not to be found in the quran
you can't say this is a use of greek
logic this would be illogical
now here's the thing
is it true to say that the best
arguments say for god's existence save
for the prophet of prophet muhammad
say for the
butlan or the falsehood of polytheism
are arguments in the quran absolutely
this is the position of ibn taymi and
this is the position i adopt
no doubt
and this is i'm this is coming from
someone who and charles i'm specializing
in academically in arguments for god's
existence i have good exposure academic
exposure to arguments for god's
existence and what i will say is this
every single argument for god's
existence
which
for example has a contingency
uh basis okay
starts i believe or the soul of it or
the foundations of it
[Music]
were they created from nothing or were
they the themselves the creators of
themselves
because almost every contingency
argument that is made whether it is made
cosmologically or ontologically
proposes that there cannot be
a world with only things which are
self-generatable and or self-maintained
and the idea of self-generation and
self-maintenance
or the impossibility of it for dependent
things comes from the fact that allah he
gives us the example the ultimate
example
of ourselves
were they created from nothing were they
themselves
or by nothing you know or were they
themselves the creators of themselves
or were they themselves the creators of
themselves
and so
all
arguments that we use actually go back
to this and this is the foundation and
they've been tamiya states that in fact
this is the best way to argue for god's
existence he he mentioned this in
his kitab
that is not to say
that you cannot use arguments
or wording which is not in the quran
to explicate or otherwise explain
how god exists or someone and how do we
know this event himself mentions it and
why am i keep mentioning it
because this is
for salafis
okay this is on therefore everyone
agrees that he understands these messiah
from uh from at least the hamburglar
slash sullivan
arthur
understanding
and he has commented on them and i've
made a video before uh speaking about
abdul rahman hassan and his discussion
clam with similar problems that are
found here i am saying oh sorry maintain
me as stated in his kitab
[Music]
and i'm paraphrasing here but there are
some people he states
that kulama kenneth
almost bloody memorized it that so there
are some people
that
you know who are more analytical yeah
who every time that the leela was more
complicated and sophisticated it was
more useful to them and this kind of
person
this kind of individual you use a calam
type
approach with them which is based on
logic
this is from ibentemia
so let me give you an easy example okay
another easy example
many people in the daoa have used hamsa
very famous line which is that a mother
cannot the universe can't
self-generate and this is similar to a
mother giving birth to herself the
impossibility of her mother giving birth
to herself
now the the phrase the mother giving
birth to herself is not in the quran
but it's actually not in a position to
the quran and in fact it has usual in
the quran
of the quranic
expression
or are they themselves the creators of
themselves
so although the exact wording is not
there
is
possible or we are jews you can say
and use
them and that words are used
[Music]
and this is what we're saying it doesn't
do
doesn't go against it and they're
rational arguments meaning they're
philosophical arguments these are the
kinds of arguments we are talking about
we are not talking about arguments which
have ta'a
of the quran we are not talking about
arguments
we are not even talking about arguments
which don't have usual in the quran
okay
now a comment i made in the in the
previous show was
erroneous i said that it would be um
it would be circular reasoning to try
and prove the quran
what i should have said and this is this
is a fine um
refutation
that it would be circular reason
reasoning to use the quran
to prove the quran by justifying that it
is true because the quran says so that's
that's actually true i should have said
it like that trying to make it within 15
one minute i'm not doing that in this
video because sometimes when you try and
make
things within a minute you end up making
blunders
so having said that you know we're not
saying
what i meant by that by the way was that
when you're speaking to an atheist he
doesn't take the quran as a
as revelation he doesn't take it as
something that they believe he believes
or she believes is true
and so you use arguments which would be
true
independent of the quran had the quran
not been there so the argument where we
created from nothing we just ourselves
the creators of ourselves
and this kind of like or the this
postulation which drives us to a third
conclusion which that in fact we had
something which is outside the cause of
us or to explain us or whatever
this is
independent of the quran being there or
not the quran doesn't have to be there
in order for that to be true
and so that's what i meant okay maybe
some people don't understand fine no no
problem the articulation i'll take the
plane no problem was my fault but this
is what i meant there are arguments when
i say some first principles they are
independent of the articulations of the
quran they don't depend on the quran
being there or not
and that's what we mean and that's what
kind of arguments need to be made in
order for our religion to be taken
seriously from people that don't believe
in it and if you abandon this then you
abandon
everything
you abandon rational inquiry then you
can't really even do dawah quite frankly
um and so that's it really oh you can
try and do that of course you can just
stand there and read the quran and
translate it and that is a fine way of
doing that one
but the moment you start using examples
or you start your arguments outside the
quran then you're
defining your own principle because
you're using philosophical argumentation
outside of the quran
and i just want to say
and i don't mean this to be rude but
brothers who's speaking about philosophy
and these kind of things
and
rational argumentation and greek logic
please be aware that this is a
specialism right this this is something
that people study academically and it's
not for anyone kulam and hebdo to come
up and speak in front of a camera to be
taken seriously about these matters and
if you want more information about this
and see what you've been saying may have
said then please look at the video that
i've done without about manhattan's very
similar mistakes